Prof: All right.
I'm Professor David Lummus and
Professor Mazzotta asked me to
come in and substitute for him
today, since he's traveling and
can't be here.
So, I guess we'll get started
and I just wanted to--
since there was a midterm last
time,
remind you more or less of what
he was talking about wherever he
left off.
The last lecture,
I suppose, was about the
relationship between Statius and
Virgil.
The specifically poetic
relationship and the ambiguity
that arises in the father/son
relationship that's staged
between Statius and Virgil.
So Statius recognizes the
centrality of Virgil for his own
poetic career and his own moral
development,
by saying, "through you I
was a poet and through you I was
a Christian,"
but at the same time his poetry
challenges that of Virgil.
Professor Mazzotta concluded
stating that,
Statius' poem is about a
tragedy--about the tragedy of
birth,
while Virgil's is about the
history-making quality of the
event of birth.
That the Thebaid
challenged Virgil's account of
the foundation and of history,
but he grew as a poet and
converted to Christianity by
engaging with Virgil's own ideas
of history,
specifically with the fourth
eclogue.
There--there's a misreading,
so the generative quality of
Virgil's poetry didn't--
wasn't intrinsic in the poetry
itself,
but was based on Statius'
particular reading of the text.
Today, we're going to be
talking about Cantos XXIV and
XXVI specifically,
but I'll be saying a few words
also about Cantos XXIII and XXV,
as a kind of frame to those two
canti.
In these two cantos--XXIV and
XXVI--they continue the
meditation and poetic
relationships that were going on
in XXI and XXII with Statius.
Now Professor Mazzotta in his
book, Dante,
Poet of the Desert,
has pointed out that Dante
utilizes the figural method of
reading history.
What about the past
pre-figures, the present and the
future in a poetic fashion in
order to understand the
genealogy of poetry--
of poets--and in order to place
himself in a typological
genealogy of poets.
In these canti,
Dante is engaged in a kind of--
in a sustained reflection,
Mazzotta says,
on literary history and the
powers of literature to engender
moral conversion,
and in probing the inevitable
limits of poetic fictions.
And there I quoted from his
book, Dante,
Poet of the Desert.
Now it says Canto XXIV,
which you read for today,
follows directly on Canto
XXIII, with a conversation
between Forese Donati and the
pilgrim.
I want to say a few words about
XXIII, especially regarding the
relationship between poetry and
gluttony.
Now, although a number of
penitents are mentioned at the
beginning of this canto,
Dante only speaks to two of
them.
Forese Donati and Bonagiunta da
Lucca, and both of them are
poets.
The first one is specifically a
friend of Dante.
Now Forese Donati was in
Dante's youth,
like I said,
a friend and they exchanged a
series of vituperative sonnets
in which they insulted each
other back and forth,
and it was filled with language
of bodily sensation.
I suppose in this canto,
the language of the
conversation between Forese and
the pilgrim sheds a new--
the memory of it causes a
bitterness in both Forese and in
the pilgrim,
and the difference between the
rhetoric of the two texts marks
a new moral vision in the
pilgrim.
Before in these sonnets,
they berated each other's wives
and their vices.
In this canto,
they recognize each other.
They treat each other like
brothers.
So it's really a reformation of
a poetic community that was in
some sense distorted by
these--six sonnets,
three for each poet.
In this canto,
the gluttonous are famished and
disfigured by hunger and their
penitence.
Donati's wife is recalled,
and she was treated with
obscenity in the sonnets,
and she is remembered as a
stilnovistic kind of woman whose
prayers,
ironically, have helped Forese
arrive at the terrace so
quickly.
In a way, it converts that kind
of gluttonous,
bodily poetry into a different
kind of moralizing poetry,
I suppose; it corrects it.
Now I guess the
connection--another connection
with gluttony is that Forese
along with a number of other
Italian poets such as Cecco
Angiolieri,
he was probably the most
famous, was a burlesque poet,
and this was also known as
goliardic poetry,
so from gula,
Latin for throat,
or for gluttony.
This oblique connection allows
Dante to speak about poetry in
this canto of gluttony.
The real connection is that
it's a worldly type of poetry
that doesn't look beyond itself,
beyond the concerns of the
flesh, I suppose.
I would like to point out at
the end of this canto,
Dante remembers their ribald
literary exchange with
bitterness,
at lines 115 at the very end,
he connects the period of his
friendship with Donati with a
dilemma back in the dark forest
in Canto I.
"If thou bring back to
mind what thou wast with me and
I with thee, the present memory
will be grievous still."
So he's pointing out that he
has a different perspective on
that time of his life.
"He that goes before me
turned me from that life some
days ago.
When the sister of him'--and I
pointed to the sun--'showed
herself round to you.
It is he that has led me
through the profound night of
the truly dead with this true
flesh that follows him;
his succours have drawn me up
thence, climbing and circling
the mountain,
which straightens you whom the
world made crooked."
The mode--or I guess the change
that Dante experiences are both
Virgil and Beatrice,
so he is pointing towards what
makes him different from what he
was a few days ago.
Actually, the exchange with
Forese was probably not that
long before the composition of
the Divine Comedy,
or at least,
not that long before the
fictional date of the Divine
Comedy.
This, in reality,
is a prelude to how he
dramatizes the differences
between his poetry and that of
his father's and brother's,
the ones that he meets in XXIV
and XXVI.
That's just as a preface,
I suppose,
to what happens in XXIV where
Dante really just juxtaposes his
own style of poetry with that of
his predecessors,
specifically embodied by
Bonagiunta da Lucca.
It's interesting that
Bonagiunta who notices that
Dante is different because
Bonagiunta da Lucca wrote a poem
to Guido Guinizelli,
who we will meet in XXVI,
criticizing how he had brought
the terminology of the
university,
the terminology of
epistemology,
and of metaphysics,
and of theology into the lyric
of love.
It's--that's probably one of
the reasons why Bonagiunta da
Lucca comes out here.
Not necessarily that he was
important for some specific
reason to Dante,
but probably because of
that--the fact that he came out
and noticed this in public of
Guinizelli-- this change.
I'd like to have a look at--in
the text when Bonagiunta da
Lucca comes out and addresses
Dante.
He says at verses 49 through
51: "But tell me if I see
here him that brought forth the
new rhymes,
beginning with "Ladies
that have intelligence of
love."
It's Bonagiunta da Lucca who
recognizes Dante and
specifically by the first line,
the incipit,
to the poem that basically
makes the center of the Vita
nuova,
the turning point in the
Vita nuova,
as you all remember,
because in this poem,
it marks the transition from a
self-centered poetry of love
where the poet praises himself
obliquely by service to the
woman,
to the lady whom he loves,
and his transition to a poetry
of praise that is mingled with
metaphysical claims for the
lady's value.
It's Dante's transition from a
courtly lyric to a more
philosophical lyric.
Now Dante responds to
Bonagiunta with a really
beautiful phrase,
and he says:
"And I said to him:
'I am one who,
when love breathes in me,
take note,
and in that manner which he
dictates within,
go on to set it forth."
Dante is claiming his novelty
and at the same time he is
saying--he's linking his own
writing of poetry to the
activity of a scribe.
He says, "I take
note" when someone--when
love dictates.
So he's explaining his
inspiration.
In Italian, the word for
'breath in' is spira,
and he dictates within Dante.
Now this inspiration,
I think, it needs to be
understood in a
theological--needs to be
understood theologically.
We'll go--I'm going to go onto
talk about Canto XXV which
explains this retrospectively in
a moment.
Let me say for now that
it--that the words noto,
'take note' in Italian,
and detta,
'dictate' in Italian,
point towards the inspiration
as this breathing in,
as the Holy Spirit,
as a movement of love within
the Trinity,
and that Dante is explaining
how poetic inspiration is really
a parallel to the unity of the
Trinity.
This inspiration comes from
within, but it's like someone
who dictates from without.
In the Monarchia,
Dante's political treatise on
empire, he describes God as the
only dictator,
the only person who dictates.
We have to understand this
description of poetic
inspiration as one coming from
an internal instantiation of the
divine.
So there is a connection
between this inspiration and the
divine.
Now Bonagiunta follows up on
this by professing to understand
the knot,
the knot that kept him and he's
like,
the Guittone da Arezzo,
Jacopo da Lentini,
who is the notary,
from arriving at that style.
The tercet that begins at line
55, he says: "Oh
brother,"
he said,
'now I see the knot that held
back the Notary and Guittone,
and me short of the sweet new
style that I hear;
I see well how your pens
followed closed behind the
dictator which assuredly did not
happen with ours,
and he that sets himself to
examine further sees nothing
else between the one style and
the other.'
And, as if satisfied,
he was silent."
Bonagiunta thinks--he has this
perspective that Purgatory gives
him on his past life and he
understands that knot--
the nodo is also used to
describe the sin of gluttony at
the beginning of Canto XXIII.
Here again, we have this lack
of moral understanding.
It's like a moral perspective
in life being paid for in the
after life, in Purgatory.
The poetry that Bonagiunta
represents was one that
concentrated on worldly beauties
and qualities,
like I said before.
It feigned a service to the
lady only to concentrate on the
self of the poet and it never
really went beyond itself.
It was a self-reflexive kind of
poetry.
In that sense,
it could be assimilated with
gluttony,
in that it absorbed and
imitated what came from without
offering forth anything,
without being generous such as
the poetry of Virgil was.
And it's interesting enough
Bonagiunta says,
"Him that brought forth
the new rhyme,"
so he brought the new rhymes
forth,
he offered them out.
Bonagiunta is able to see the
difference between the two
styles of poetry at this point,
but I think he doesn't
recognize the kind of uniqueness
that Dante is claiming for
himself here,
because he says,
"That your pens follow
close behind the dictator."
So he's pluralizing what Dante
says only about himself.
He says in Italian,
I' mi son un che and
people have pointed out that
this--
'I am one who,' is both humble
and it's like,
'I am one who among others who
do this,' but it's also--
it's also pointing out his
uniqueness.
Others have pointed out that it
echoes,
line 314 of Exodus,
Ego sum qui sum,
this is what God says to Moses,
"I am who am,"
that this self-reflexive,
mi son un che,
is an expression of uniqueness,
couched in humble language.
Dante is really pointing out
that he is doing something
unique with his poetry,
that perhaps Bonagiunta doesn't
really recognize the full
extent.
He's--if there is a school of
the dolcestilnovo,
if there is this Sweet New
Style which composes a school--
like the Sicilian school that
preceded it,
which I'm sure Professor
Mazzotta talked about in
relation to the Vita
nuova--
then Dante is creating
something new within that
school.
That's, I think,
what's going on here in those
lines.
I suppose what Dante is doing
in this canto,
is marking an extreme contrast
between his own poetry and that
of the people who came before
him.
There is a line that divides
these two schools,
the Guittone,
who is a Tuscan poet who
imitated Sicilian poetry,
the Sicilians who imitated a
Provençal poetry,
he's detaching himself from
them because of their lack of a
moral purpose,
I suppose, in their poetry,
which Bonagiunta recognizes
retrospectively.
Now I just wanted to point out
as the--as this conversation
comes to an end,
Dante describes at tercet 64
through 69, how the penitents
depart.
He says, "As birds that
winter along the Nile sometimes
make a troop in the air,
then fly with more speed and go
in file,
so all the people that were
there, facing round,
quickened their steps being
light with both leanness and
desire;
and as one tired with running
lets his companions go on and
then walks till the heaving of
his chest is so relieved,
so Forese let the holy flock
pass and come on with me
behind..."
I just wanted to point out the
contrast here;
the image of birds probably
reminds us of the image of birds
in Canto V of the
Inferno.
They were just--the sinners
were described as cranes who
were being buffeted about by a
tempest.
They kept returning to the same
spot in a circle,
like an eternal return.
Here, the same kinds of birds,
these love poets,
are coming together in a troop
and moving along together,
and not only are they moving
along together,
they're moving forward.
So there's a progress
that's--that opposes the
circularity of the storm of
birds in Inferno V,
and this will come up again
also in Canto XXVI.
Now I know we didn't read it
for today, Canto XXV of
Purgatory,
but I think it sheds some
light.
I'm going to say a few words
about it, because I think it
sheds some light on what Dante
is talking about in relation to
inspiration.
We talked about that earlier.
Now what happens here is Dante
asks--
Dante is perplexed about how
the sinners can be punished with
their bodies if they don't have
bodies,
so he asks this of Statius.
The whole canto basically--he
asks this of Virgil I guess and
Virgil says, it's better if
Statius explains it to you.
The pretext of it all is,
how can this happen?
What is the physics of it?
What is the biology of the soul
basically in the afterlife?
What Statius does in explaining
this, explains how God engenders
the soul, how he creates the
soul.
In placing the discourse of the
generation of the soul and the
body between two cantos that are
basically all about poetic
inspiration,
Dante I think is drawing a
parallel between divine
inspiration,
divine creation,
and poetic generation,
and poetic creation.
Student:
Can you say that again?.
Prof: Okay,
he usually has a parallel--
he's making a parallel between
poetic generation,
inspiration from--and poetic
inspiration and the divine
creation of the soul,
the inspiration of the divine
in the creation of the soul.
I'm going to go on and explain
what I mean.
I'm just trying to--does that
make sense?
Student:
Yes..
Prof: Okay,
all right.
I'll slow down a second.
Basically he's staging here the
relationship between
predecessors and new poets,
so himself and his past
basically.
He's explaining how he is born
out of the past but is not
imitative, and is not--can't be
merely reducible to that past.
I can read a little bit of this.
It's a bit scholastic I
suppose, but it's okay.
I can read it all;
it might explain it better for
you.
He says at lines 38--37,38:
"Perfect blood,
which is never drunk by the
thirsty veins and is left like
food thou removest from the
table,
takes in the heart informing
power for all the bodily
members,
like that which takes its
course through the veins to
become these.
Further digested,
it descends where silence is
fitter than speech,
and thence drops afterwards on
another's blood in the natural
vessel.
There the one mingles with the
other,
and the one fitted to be the
passive and the other,
on account of the perfect place
from which it springs,"
that is the heart,
"active,
and this, so united,
begins to operate;
first coagulating,
then quickening,
that to which,
for its material,
it has given consistency."
Here, I think it gets a little
bit more interesting,
he says: "The active force
having become a soul,
like a plant's,
but so far different that it is
on the way and the other already
on the shore,
then operates to the point that
now it moves and feels,
like a sea fungus,
and from that goes onto produce
organs for the faculties of
which it is the seed.
Now, my son,
develops and spreads the force
that is from the heart of the
begetter, where nature makes
provision for all the members.
But how from animal it becomes
a child?
Thou seest not yet..."
I'm going to skip a little bit
more to the top of the next
page: "Open thy breast to
the truth that follows and know
that as soon as the articulation
of the brain is perfected in the
embryo,
the first Mover turns to it,
rejoicing over such handiwork
of nature,
and breathes into it a new
spirit,"
he breathes into it just like
the inspiration that Dante
claimed for his own poetry
before,
"a spirit full of power,
which draws into its own
substance that which it finds
active there and becomes a
single soul that lives and
feels,
and itself revolves upon
itself."
What I think is going on here
is that ostensibly--
basically, Statius describes
the creation of the body--
the biological creation of the
body,
which comes from the mingling
of bloods, right?
Then after that,
how the animal that is created,
basically, is given a soul by
God but becomes a rational--
becomes a human being and the
human being--
the human here is described--he
translates it as a 'child' but
the word that's actually used is
a fante.
Now fante would be
basically--
it's derived from the Greek
word for speech,
so a fante would be--one who
speaks,
so how an animal becomes one
who speaks.
So humanity is defined in a
sense by the fact that we can
speak and reason basically.
So what happens here,
I suppose, is that even though
the father is the--generates the
body, the soul is directly
created by God.
So that there's two kinds of
individualities I suppose.
You have the body and the soul,
and the soul is a uniqueness
that is directly created and
inspired by God.
If you consider this
poetically, even though Dante
may have been influenced or in a
sense created,
by the poets that came before
him, nonetheless he has his own
kind of direct inspiration that
separates him from the poets
that came before him,
at least that's how I
understand it.
I think it's connected that
Dante points out the connection,
especially by the word
spira,
he uses the word spira
or inspiration twice.
They imitate each other,
they parallel each other.
The connection between
fante,
the child who speaks is a
direct connection to language,
the language of poetry.
That's, I think,
it explains retrospectively
what Dante is claiming in Canto
XXIV about his poetic
inspiration,
this difference between his own
poetry and that of his
predecessors.
Now Canto XXVI,
he passes into the terrace of
the lustful.
Here he meets his own staged
poetic father,
Guido Guinizelli.
He recognizes his father and
his debt to his father,
and at the same time,
he's recognized as a brother by
his father.
So his individuality as a poet
is recognized--the recognition
is staged here.
The paternal relationship
becomes a fraternal one.
What I'm trying to point out
with this--the biological
embryology is that he can be
seen as derivative and different
at the same time.
So he's the same and he's
distinguishable at the same
time.
This canto is in sharp contrast
to XXIV I think,
because Dante wanted to
distance himself from those
poets in XXIV and here he wants
to show a similarity.
He's trying to assimilate
himself with a certain kind of
poetry that was--for which
metaphysics, epistemology and
theology were all central.
So it's a philosophical kind of
love poetry.
I think he also redeems this
love tradition,
which in a certain sense,
was condemned in Inferno V with
Francesca.
So this courtly love tradition
that was--
that caused in a way I--or at
least Francesca claimed caused
her downfall in saying that 'the
Galehault was the book' in
Inferno V.
Here he redeems it and he
purges it and cleanses it.
You can start off by reading
the tercet that begins at line
94,
whenever Guido Guinizelli
identifies himself to the
pilgrim,
it says: "Such as in the
grief of Lycurgus,
the two sons became on seeing
their mother again,
I became, but with more
restraint, when I heard speak
his own name,
the father of me and of others
my betters,
whoever have used the sweet and
graceful rhymes of love,
and without hearing or speech,
I went on a long way and
thought gazing at him and did
not for the fire go near
him."
Dante, I guess,
he loses his faculty of speech
here, because he's in awe almost
like a child before his father.
So his behavior imitates his
relationship to Guinizelli.
I'll point here as well that
one of the main differences,
I suppose, between the two
poets is symbolized by the
casting of the shadow on the
fire.
His--the reality of his
presence there in his body,
is what's really--is what the
physical aspect that separates
him from the others.
It stands in for the aspect of
his poetry that separates him
from the rest of these poets as
well.
Since we're talking about
poetic genealogy,
it's interesting that Dante
is--he refers to him as a father
but then Guinizelli respond by
saying: "Oh brother,
he there whom I point out to
thee, was a better craftsman of
the mother tongue,
verses of love and tales of
romance he has surpassed them
all."
In these fifteen,
twenty lines Dante is a child
before his father and is then
equated with his father,
by being a brother.
So they're put on the same
level and they're assigned
another father,
so the grandfather of them all
becomes the father,
and this father,
I guess, who's not named is
Arnaut Daniel.
An important poet for Dante in
Le Rime Petrose,
the 'Stony Rhymes' which
Professor Mazzotta mentioned,
Dante imitated him in those
rhymes.
He was a poet famous for his
difficulty in reading--it was
very, very hard to understand an
example of the trobar
clus.
In this same paragraph,
these same series of tercets,
paragraph in the English,
again we have the
differentiation of the kind of
school,
I suppose, that Dante is
associating himself with and the
other school with which he wants
to differentiate himself,
because he says that like
Arnaut is different from the one
from Limoges,
so he is different from
Guittone--Guittone da Arezzo who
is named alongside Bonagiunta da
Lucca and Jacopo da Lentini.
So he's separating himself
from--he's aligning himself with
the different kind of poetry.
He kind of reinforces the kind
of genealogy he wants to create
for himself.
Now this genealogy too,
I guess, has its own
consequences in the modern age
because the words in Italian for
the better craftsmen,
il miglior fabbro were
the words with which
T.S. Eliot dedicated The
Wasteland to Ezra Pound,
as you probably know.
This conversation here really
becomes an emblem for happy
poetic relationships,
I suppose, which you can
recognize--
you're better at recognizing
your forefathers,
and at the same time,
come out with something that
you recognize as new.
Some scholars have pointed
out--we didn't--
I don't think you concentrated
much on Inferno XXIV and
XXV,
where Dante utilizes a number
of metaphors from Ovid and Lucan
and he has this--
there's this topos called the
taciat nunc,
be silent now Lucan,
be silent now Ovid he says,
and he basically steals from
their lines without recognizing
them,
saying that he is surpassing
them but at the same time as
he's surpassing them,
he's using their own poetry to
surpass them.
People have pointed out that in
these canti of the
thieves,
that Dante is participating in
the sin by stealing from Ovid
and Lucan and that this kind of
poetic relationship is a
negative one,
that he's stealing the identity
of the other.
Well here we have a different
kind of understanding about
poetic identity.
We have one that recognizes the
paternity of the father,
while at the same time,
allows the son to come into his
own,
and that's coming into his own
is, I think,
pointed out by Dante the poet
whenever he says at--
between lines 130 and 140:
"Then perhaps to give
place to others who were near
him,
he disappeared through the fire
as though the water--
as through the water a fish
goes to the bottom."
Here the father moves out of
his way so that Dante can go on
and I guess he can progress;
he doesn't get in his way.
If Dante recognizes these
people, these poets as his
predecessors how does he
differentiate himself?
How, in this canto,
does he differentiate himself
from them?
Then we can look at it through
the lens of Canto XXV where the
paternal virtue--the generation
of the soul granted the paternal
virtue.
Its place, while simultaneously
claimed a direct creation of the
soul by the inspiration of the
Holy Spirit.
I think Dante's poetic
individuality grows out of the
artifice,
the style that they concentrate
on here,
the sweet detti d'amore,
the sweet sayings of love that
he attributes to Guinizelli,
so it grows out of the
stylistic artifice that these
two poets represent are and
Guido to form something new,
a new kind of speech,
a new kind of poetic speech
that's imbibed with the divine
and guided by theological and
moral meaning.
I think we can see this and how
these pair of poets are cleansed
and how they're represented in
this canto.
For example,
Guinizelli, when he first calls
out to Dante before we know who
he is,
before he's even identified
himself,
I think it's around line 17 and
following,
he says, "Oh thou that
goest behind the others not from
tardiness but perhaps from
reverence,
answer me who burn with thirst
and with fire."
Now the line in Italian is e
in foco ardo.
Now this is a direct quotation
of Guinizelli's own poetry in a
sonnet which he says,
in gran pena e foco
ardo, "in great pain
and fire I burn."
So in foco ardo is
basically repeated verbatim.
The love poet who's burning for
his lady metaphorically in his
sonnet is now burning literally
in the penitent fire that's
purging his sin.
I think this punishment shows
how the perspective of Purgatory
is really modifying--
giving us a moral sense to the
love poetry that Guinizelli--
school of love poetry that
Guinizelli belonged to.
Another thing that
differentiates them,
like I said before,
with Dante's shadow showing
that he's actually there,
and that he's in his body,
in the flesh,
points to something else,
and that is that his lady is
actually the beginning--
started a chain of grace.
That there is a connection that
his--
not just a metaphysical
connection or epistemological
connection and value to his
lady,
but a theological value as well.
Like he says at line 58,
"I go up hence not to be
longer blind;
a lady is above who gains grace
for me by which I bring my
mortal part through your
world."
What these poets couldn't
recognize in their own lifetime
Dante is able to because of his
poetry,
this bringing together that he
does,
which is actually the newness
in the Sweet New Style,
I think, which isn't just
metaphysical,
but it's theological.
To put it in another way,
if Guinizelli,
Arnaut Daniel,
Guido Cavalcanti,
who's not mentioned here again,
if for these poets the lady was
a philosophical or intellectual
phantasm I suppose,
for Dante she is a real woman
who enacted a real change in his
life and that caused that chain
of grace to descend into his own
personal story.
His poetry, I think,
seeks to close the gap between
the metaphysical,
theological reality of God and
the historical contingent
reality of history and Dante's
own personal story in that
history.
Love poetry for Dante takes on
an entirely new meaning here,
and I think Guinizelli shows
that he understands this
difference with a perspective
that Purgatory gives him.
Towards the end of the canto
when he asks Dante to say a
Pater noster for him,
to Christ whenever he enters
heaven,
so it's really a conversion I
think of love poetry,
a purgation of the worldliness
of love poetry.
Finally, I want to say--we're
going to end a little bit early
because I actually have to run
to another building to teach
right after this--
my own class.
I want to conclude by saying a
few words about Arnaut.
It's very peculiar that
Dante--this is the only place I
believe in the Divine
Comedy where another modern
romance language is quoted
that's not Italian basically.
I could be mistaken,
but I'm pretty sure it's the
only place.
Now Arnaut was famous,
like I said,
for his obscurity,
the extreme difficulty of his
poetic expression,
and here what does Dante do to
him?
Even though he quotes him in
the original,
he didn't really write these
lines,
these lines are Dante's,
but what he does is he makes
this difficult hidden poet come
out in the open.
To quote him,
he says, "So much does
your courteous question please
me that I neither can nor would
conceal myself from you.
I am Arnaut who weep and sing
as I go.
I see with grief past follies
and see rejoicing the day I
hoped for before me.
Now I beg of you by that
goodness which guides you to the
summit of the stairway to take
thought and do time for my pain.
Then he hid himself from the
fire that refines him."
There's a little bit of
a--Dante's playing here with
Arnaut's own language.
If he was a difficult poet of
love,
Dante really makes him come out
into the open and say what he is
saying,
so--here also are typical words
from the Provençal
tradition such as the value--
valor, cortes and
cantant: they all take on
different kinds of meaning.
That before the valor,
or value of the love poet was
not what it is here;
it takes on a completely
different meaning in Purgatory.
He really stages in Arnaut's
own words the purification,
cleansing, and bringing out
into openness of what love
poetry should really be,
where it should really lead you.
I guess to conclude I wanted to
say that in the next canto,
you'll see Dante submitting
himself to the same kind of
purgation as these poets.
If these poets are cleansed by
this wall of--
by this fire that refines them,
he will end up passing through
a wall of flame in order to get
to where he can enter into the
terrestrial paradise.
So that he is in reality
cleansing himself of the same
kind of issue,
I suppose.
I guess now I can take a few
questions if you have any.
Hopefully, it wasn't too
disjointed--the lecture,
but I'm happy to answer any
questions you might have,
or try to.
Student:
In Canto XXIV,
Dante refers to Statius as his
being more slowly than he would
>,
and I know that there's a lot
of different critical
interpretations of that line,
I'm wondering how we can
interpret it as sort of looking
later to Canto XXV and the idea
of the proper father/son issues?
Statius sort of by slowing his
journey towards God to stay with
Virgil going against Dante's
idea or does--can we reconcile
the two?.
Prof: I think you can
reconcile them.
I mean whenever Dante--whenever
he meets Guinizelli,
he's silent.
He doesn't automatically make
himself--he doesn't move his
father out of the way.
Statius and Dante both know
that Virgil is not going to be
able to go the whole way.
They know that he's only going
to be able to lead them a
certain amount of the trip,
of the journey.
So I guess--I would interpret
it as an act of reverence,
just like Dante's silence,
whenever he meets Guinizelli is
an act of reverence.
He doesn't push them out of the
way and he doesn't trample them.
He's not in a hurry, I suppose.
Does that make any sense at all?
I think it's--the way you could
interpret it Statius is--
if you want to see him
interpret that as him as slowing
his way on the way to God
basically,
then you could interpret it as
an act of reverence to the
person who allowed him to
actually be there and not in
Limbo.
That's how I would interpret
it, I suppose.
That Dante in this--in XXVI,
is reverent to his father,
so at the same time he is
showing how he's moving beyond
him by giving a theological
meaning to their questionable
worldly love poetry.
Does that answer your question?
Student:
When Dante talks about the
inspiration which you've
identified as the inspiration of
the Holy Spirit,
is he making love synonymous
with the Holy Spirit?
And if so, looking back at the
Vita nuova,
when he personifies love in the
masculine I've always sort of
thought of--in literature,
when you read religious poetry
and stuff, the Holy Spirit's
often sort of a feminized noun,
are those things one and the
same to him, love and the Holy
Spirit?.
Prof: I think there
that he's thinking of--
I think at that point he's
thinking of love--
I think Thomas Aquinas mentions
love as the procession of love,
as the movement of the Holy
Spirit within the Trinity
between the Father and the Son,
so that both really are
within--participate in the same
spirit.
So yes I think in that spot,
he is really talking about love
as the Holy Spirit,
as this kind of--or at least as
parallel to it.
It's ambiguous.
He says--he doesn't really say
that love is the Holy Spirit
does he?
He's purposefully ambiguous I
think, because love poetry
always has that--the possibility
of leading you astray,
because it's an aesthetic
practice.
It's dolce;
it's sweet.
So I think that the--that yes
he is talking about love as the
Holy Spirit,
as this divine love,
but he's also talking about--
so I guess in reality that
there is a connection between
the contingent and historical
world and the metaphysical world
of God,
but that he leaves it ambiguous
because it can always be
misinterpreted and the aesthetic
can always lead you back down to
the terrestrial realm.
Does that make sense?
Student:
Why do you think it's--or what
do you think is the significance
of the fact that the biological
discussion of inspiration of God
breathing the soul into the
infant?
The fact that it's handled by
Statius and that Dante really
highlights that by saying--he
has Statius say,
if it's Virgil's will that he
explains but can't refuse
it--what's the significance that
says, I want Statius to handle
this at his discretion?
Because at other times I think
Virgil, even though he's not
permitted to know God or to go
to heaven, can still speak about
divine workings.
So I don't think it's out of--I
mean for me it's not out of
Virgil's capacity but I just
couldn't understand why he has
Statius explain it..
Prof: Okay,
well I guess if the question
really had been about what is
the nature of the soul,
what is Aristotle saying in the
De Anima about--
maybe Virgil could have told
him about that,
but the actual question is what
is the nature--
how does the soul live in the
afterlife?
That is an entirely Christian
question,
that's based on Christian
theology,
so I think the fact that Virgil
defers to Statius there is
showing--
is connected with the fact that
the question is actually about
the afterlife and the afterlife
is specifically a Christian
context that Statius is
permitted to know and not
Virgil.
Does that make sense?
Student:
Yeah..
Prof: Okay.
Student:
Like I said,
it is beyond his realm,
beyond Virgil's capacity..
Prof: Technically,
but the fact that he actually
asked Virgil first--
I don't know,
maybe he's saying that it's
actually Aristotle,
this idea of the immortality of
the soul and the after--
it's actually there and perhaps
Virgil could answer it,
but then Virgil defers to
Statius because it's a
theological question that he's
not privy to.
Does that--okay.
We're going to end a little bit
early;
I hope that's okay,
so I can go change gears here.
All right, thank you for your
attention and for putting up
with me.
All right, thank you.